So we look up the definition of an autoimmune disease and we see autoimmune disease. It's when my body is attacking my old tissue
Well, that's not good. So I'm gonna ask my doctor. You diagnosed me with rheumatoid arthritis. That's an autoimmune disorder
Why is it happening doctor? Well, that's an autoimmune disorder and it's idiopathic, which is Latin for her. We have no idea
So
That's typically the best the deepest answer that you get, but that's not good enough. Okay, why so what is an autoimmune disease?
Well, I looked it up. It says well your body is attacking your old tissue. Well, let's expand that definition a little bit
It's not your body that's attacking your old tissue. It's your immune system
So either a hyperfiring TH1 or a hyperfiring TH2 response is it destroyed your old cells?
Okay, well, that's a little bit clear. We know that the immune system killing your old cells, but still why?
Well, your immune system remember I said it does one thing and it does one thing. Well, what does it do?
Kills things. That's what it's supposed to do. So your immune system therefore by a very definition is only supposed to turn on
Again, something that it can kill
What are things that are killable that can enter your body as pathogens? We name them viruses bacteria
Parasites, molds, funguses, right?
Living organisms. Those are called biotoxins living organisms that enter your body your immune system is supposed to kill those things
So if my immune system is healthy, hey, it's it's a healthy immune system
I will fire a TH1 TH2 response and be able to kill that thing
Most of the time so here's the problems. Here's some things that cause an autoimmune disorder
There are some biotoxins living organisms
Bailey bacteria that have the ability to go inside the cell now bacteria are typically too large to go inside the cell
So you're exposed to them you breathe them on me
They went into my bloodstream. They're circulated around my bloodstream as long as they stay within my bloodstream my immune system
Should be able to kill them as long as I have a healthy enough immune system
The problem is is that there are some things viruses viruses are small enough to go inside of a cell
Now if a virus enters a cell and there's some bacteria that can go inside of the cell
That's the problem with Lyme disease if if there is a virus or a bacteria that goes inside the cell
What happens is your cell puts up this chemical marker on the outside of the cell?
In a sense you can say it's like if you went into rob a bank and the cashier goes okay
And she pushes the red button under the counter
And it calls the police and tells them there's somebody robbing our bank and the police send this watch
Team surround the entire bank until they catch the robber well your body is much more efficient and waiting out for the robber to come out of the
Bank what your body does when it's virus enters the cell the cell puts up a marker on the outside of the cell
Your lymphocytes in macrophages will surround that entire cell and destroy the cell thereby killing the pathogen
It's very efficient. We sacrifice one cell so what it was gonna die in six weeks anyhow
But we killed the pathogen and we destroyed it
However, there are some
Nasty viruses Lyme being one of them that could go inside the cell and disable that marker
So think of it the teller inside the cell is hitting the red button, but nobody's coming to the rescue
So that pathogen can reproduce reproduce reproduce and since we got somebody talking to Lyme today
We'll use another type of pathogen that does that very well and if you ever heard of helicobacter pylori H pylori
It's
It's it's a nasty
bacterial infection that has the ability to go inside the cell and disable that marker and reproduce and because they're
Opportunistic organisms when the immune response has finally slowed down or died down
It goes outside the cell and reproduces some more you fire at other immune response
It goes back inside the cell and hides again
Nasty things so if I have one of those nasty type
Bacterial or viruses that have the ability to disable the marker inside the cell my immune system cannot find it and then cannot
Effectively kill it so it's constantly fired in a response against
This pathogen that isn't very killable
because it's elusive
Follow me
So when I do fire a TH1 response and now it suppresses and I fire a TH2 response and it hides inside the cell by
TH2 cytokines the chemicals that are in that TH2 response that are
Responsible for making antibodies are now looking for I don't know what I'm supposed to make an antibody against and here
I'm at the you know the thyroid gland and I don't and so it starts making antibodies against your own tissue
That's what an autoimmune disease is what your immune system
Particularly your TH2 response is unable to find the pathogen
What we now call the antigen something that the immune system is turned on against it's unable to find the
Antigen that your a TH1 system has been constantly trying to fire and kill it can create antibodies against the tissue that the response
Happened it
So then I can end up having thyroid antibodies and
Then my immune system by TH1 system starts firing again, and it starts
Destroying thyroid cells not good. That's called Hashimoto's or Graves disease if it's a hyper thyroid
So that's what the definition of an autoimmune disease
Expanded is that when my immune system starts destroying my old cells
Because the antigen in question was not able to be found and my immune system by TH2 side started to create antibodies
Against my own tissue and therefore my my immune system by TH1 cytokine started destroying my own tissue
That's what an autoimmune disease is